I don't know what is wrong with there's
just so many [ __ ] heck
this I mean this is so obnoxious that
we're getting this
okay a lot of problems in the field
defined by wable
distributions is it good at the
prediction of distributions
I think pretty much everyone just sticks
a gaussian on action outputs and calls
it a day at the
moment I don't know your specific
I think technically you can just Chuck
any distribution you want on the action
the stupid Bots I swear damn it I didn't
the chat window open fast enough to St
to clear that
one I'm just trying to fix right now
there's an annoying bug where the
containers lose GPU access and it
crashes the jobs
toen we will hopefully see if he runs
now
there we
go
run got to get these experiments prun
and then we'll check uh we'll check a
couple things sh
okay so that should handle
this this thing
here I'd love to know why my host
drivers randomly uh my ethernet drivers
randomly crash that'd be
nice let's see if I can figure that out
real quick maybe there's been something
since I last checked
to make an SVG
puffer there's no way it does better
than our
puffer we have a very nice
one took quite a bit of work to get this
one done
I can't believe I'm the only one who's
getting this
now we have a couple uh sweeps to look
at so we get this one
it's funny that this gets these random
ones and
then immediately jumps up so we'll have
to figure out why that is but this is
perfectly good as far as sweeps go it
looks
like couple high cost ones mostly lower
cost parito front is
building now this
fine and we'll see what this comes up
with we just reran this and then this
one's a little
weird we do better than this normally
right
but it's gone down to Min cost for some
reason yeah 50
protein better than previous G yeah I'm
telling you that these these models are
not going to be good for art until they
can actually like edit and like do the
process the way that an artist would and
I don't particularly care too much
either like they'll be cool that'll be
really cool
but I'm also more than happy to you know
be supporting
artists it's one of the things where
it's kind of cool to have it done by
people
well let me think about this now we
have we're kind of at a good spot here
where everything's mostly where it needs
to
be I need to run a ton of experiments
of let me make a quick list here are all
the things that
um I think I just made like a priority
list recently didn't
I I never actually look at these lists
sometimes I write them though
so there's
um here are some things there
is re Jacks and creation
sometimes I just like to sort of think
about you know what are the important
things for puffer
next I'm going to be right back we'll
get a few of those experiments running
and then I'm going to come look at this
and then I I want to like sort of
prioritize some stuff um cuz I still
have a few algorithm ideas to try
out yeah I'll be back in a bit though
hold
okay so I've had uh Hey Su I've had um
one in ENT thought total in the last
several minutes which is that I should
probably do the uh the stuff for Jacob's
lab because it's pretty quick and it
would be uh relatively straightforward
all I have to do really is figure out
how to get Jack to play nice on the
container um would be a good time to
upgrade a whole bunch of stuff on the
container the only thing is I don't know
if I want to do container Dev today it's
kind of a pain
oh I do I don't plan on using it for
training it's uh it's just uh the Jack
based environments so we take the jackm
we take the data uh without copying it
we take it we put it into a torch tensor
and then we run it through puffer
right mind you I don't love torch
either but um
yeah Jack has Jax has some good stuff
but then they [ __ ] it up with like
really stupid
ideology I swear there are like so many
different Frameworks where it's like oh
this is good software and then they just
functional throw it for no
reason ah everything should be
functional a lot of functional code
doesn't function
I honestly think I rather like very
light o to uh like heavy
functional as stupid as that
is especially in Python like python kind
of forces you to just like you don't
have to do fancy anything but it kind of
at least forces you to put your methods
on
classes
um so I realized this recently cuz I was
thinking like okay if you just had a a
struct type in Python right could you
write code that looks like C in it and
would it be better and I think the
answer is no because I mean structs are
fundamentally typed right so you need to
type them and then your methods also end
up being typed on top of those because
you no longer have the information that
you get from having the method attached
to the struct right so you no longer get
the type of the things added to it so
you have to like add this annotations to
it but then you're doing typed python
which is worthless so I think it's
better to just have basically do the
same thing but just attach most methods
to classes and not do any inheritance
and not do any other fancy stuff
um I don't like it but it's the language
kind of pushes you to
that it's so funny because when I'm
writing C I like I never miss any of the
oop features right but then when I'm
writing python really hard not to do
stuff with classes it's I mean that just
means it's language design drives me
nuts I like c c is nice
didn't know any different yeah I mean I
I had the same
thing it's annoying because like it
makes so much sense right when you're
taught it and then the languages a lot
of the languages that you're taught in
like kind of enforce it so it's like
it's almost impossible to discover on
your own like you it takes very many
years to like slowly discover all the
ways that it's making you write terrible
code
impulse worth PR oh that'll be so
good I think that with your end like
you've done so much work on this project
that it's going to be worthwhile to like
spend some time trying to make it look a
little bit more interesting visually um
I can help that a bit like did you see
Spencer retextured his environment he
just like loaded some Textures in and
stuff and now he turned his like block
environment into like you know space
space 3D Puzzle
thing easy to get building M script and
cuz C
mob I mean you just load in some
textures pretty
I think pretty much of these the only
two that I can actually realistically do
I can look for core perf
enhancements or I could do the puffer
Jack integration because I don't really
want to start anything big until I clean
up the existing
Dev see make
Dev I've heard it's we literally have m
scripton in uh did you not see we have m
scripton in the build sh file
that's how we build
I mean the only thing is if your build
is wrong right then it's going to give
you a blank thing and you have to debug
in webbland which isn't fun but I think
that'll be the same with
cmake I mean BET's a newer programmer
right like you
would yeah I when bet says something is
very hard it's it doesn't always mean
it's very hard right
I'm sure it would have been very
difficult many years ago as well for me
too
I'd like a quick overview of the policy
code
now I can confirm it
saying before I spend a lot
of did you think I didn't change a bunch
of stuff with the policy literally look
Captain all I did was
this all I did I don't even think it
affects anything to be honest with
loading oh your policy code okay yeah I
can look at your policy
grid did the runs die
again yeah let me hang on I'll get this
in a second let me just see if my runs
keep dying that's not good
hanging no it's not the driver this time
that's
fixed how do we see where this is stuck
for some reason P spy wasn't working
before
spy I get this permission to
arrow and I can't even pseudo my way out
of
it with pi spy
Docker oh maybe you can run it outside a
Docker actually
that I [ __ ] hate python so much
sometimes like the cooling is just
ass it literally tells you you can't do
this without a VM like what
this has got to be new as well that
didn't used to do
this it like actually it here's this is
the crazy thing it doesn't let you
install system packages because it's so
python is so ass that uh the maintainers
know that you'll break [ __ ] if you don't
use VM so everything has to go in a
[ __ ]
VM that's how ass python is
I actually think that the language isn't
terrible the tooling sucks the language
is actually pretty damn
nice um tooling is just
process it's in the backward pass as
well
running well this one's
running and then this one's
dead or is this one maybe it's just in
between runs there weren't 16 of these
before maybe it's just taking a while to
actually start the new run because of
the
uh I think it is just taking a while to
start the new runs okay so we might have
to do some optimization on the GPS but
that's fine otherwise
who okay next
thing is going to
is kind of want to do the Jack stuff
honestly because the thing is I got to
like that will give me an excuse to
upgrade the containers
that's the reason I want to do
it ah my bad I get distracted easily you
have to remind me on these things
you can put these in the uh the policy
you can put these either in the like as
defaults or you can put these in like
policy and they'll get past his arcs by
the way
oh the one thing is also in depth we
deleted the uh the clean RL
layer externally manag
disclaimer uh that's just uh that's just
an abun to uh that's literally all that
is is um python wanting you to use
Virtual lens
annoying Docker it lets you in Docker I
don't know how it actually knows it's in
a Docker but in Docker it lets you
install everything
systemwide yeah okay I can tell you
already that you probably aren't going
to want to Port this to c because it's
just this is pretty complicated let me
see
what we have
here each bite in the map
observation contains four
fine oh well I've seen much more
complicated networks right but um the
goal is to get it shorter hey Spencer
we're just reviewing the policy at the
moment we're definitely going to
integrate a impulse for soon and by the
way Captain we can technically put the
make stuff in uh the dev branch that
will be fine I'm going to merge I
actually have a big merge to Dev coming
up today or tomorrow um and then we can
do
that I'm still not so sure on that by
the way but I don't know we'll have to
we will have to look at it but it's I
understand the reasoning it's like it's
it's so ABS to need extra
tooling if it deletes setup.py though I
think I think I'm okay with it if it
deletes setup.py provided we can
actually get the thing to generate like
I don't want cake to have to generate a
giant ass build Command right if it can
generate like a similar build command
that uh to what you would do manually in
build sh but figuring out all the
platform specific details so you can run
that separately then I'm
happy I want to look into doing
yeah nice to not have to oh right
because your cmake was just for impulse
Force well we have to build it somehow
don't we when we PR it cuz if your build
is using cake right and we're still
using um our setup.py stuff
we need some way to get like box 2D
Linked
though cmake for Python and build a h
for ocean Dev yeah I'd be very happy
with that and the cool thing with that
right is that you can leave uh you can
let cmake do the initial builds for like
uh this from Source builds or whatever
and then you can assume that those are
there right for the dependencies and
then build sh doesn't have to do that it
just has to like pull them
in and that one we don't have to worry
about static versus dynamic or whatever
because it's just for local
Captain
so this does what like a lazy layer
would do for you
right but it's not lazy you've gone and
computed everything
manually so I think what happened here
is that you saw that uh I manually code
the layer
sizes um and then you said oh well but I
want I don't want to use the lazy layers
but I want it to be done without me
having to manually update it so you did
this so in my mind this is kind of the
same as doing Lazy layer because that's
like way too much math for me to read
and have any idea of what the output
size is going to be right the output
size is just going to be some number and
I have no idea what it is the reason
that I code stuff manually is to prevent
you from like accidentally increasing
the observation size and then having the
output be a million dimensions and not
realizing it um so I think if you just
pick one either lazy or you just
hardcode the output layer which is